lamier on va utiliser les fleurs pour
décorer nos rouleaux de printemps des
pâquerettes des violettes des géraniums
et des pissenlits toutes ces plantes
qu'on a l'habitude d'arracher et
pourtant elles peuvent être cuisinées
finalement est-ce que j'aime faire c'est
un peu de réveiller un peu les les
consciences entre guillemets enfin
donner ce goût en fait pour ces sauvages
jaunes qui sont pas très appréciés qui
sont très bonnes dans nos assiettes et
en plus très belle après une cueillette
en pleine nature leur est au tri les
pétales sont détachés les plantes lavées
et le tout est mixé
ces mauvaises herbes vont être
métamorphosées en de véritables places
savoureux au menu soda original au
lierre et rouleau de printemps au
pâquerettes au fur et à mesure dans
notre assiette oh là là là là là là
un mélange de saveurs étonnant c'est
génial
c'est joli en plus
et encore j'ai mangé son sauce
méfiez-vous toutes les mauvaises herbes
ne sont pas bonnes à manger avant de les
cueillir assurez-vous de bien les
connaître